quand xavier la fré imagine une
construction lego sur l'univers de star
wars il voit grand une planète
désertique fourmillant de détails
un vaisseau spatial emblématiques de la
saga sans oublier la base de l'empiré
galactique
si vous êtes sur 5000 pièces ici vous
êtes à peu près sur 6000 places
également en construction déconstruction
intégrale qui sont faites entièrement en
briques de lego ce chercheur en biologie
animale des 10 tout son temps libre à
ses créations des soirées des week-ends
entiers à modéliser l'ensemble en 3d sur
ordinateur
avant de jouer le rôle de chef
d'orchestre auprès de la vingtaine de
contributeurs du projet
quand on commence on se dit on va passer
une heure deux heures dessus et puis en
fait on se rend compte qu'on a passé
quatre heures à faire ce design dollars
derrière cette passion une double
motivation créer et donné l'envi de
ready
ce qui me fait rêver c'est ce plaisir
qu'on a de construire de créer on va
transporter sur des expositions et en
fait on va transmettre fait se plaisait
on va transmettre cette envie de créer à
des gars des adultes mais à des enfants
à tout le monde autre collectionneur
autre univers joël perrault trouve son
bonheur dans la conception de ville
imaginaire lui n'a pas de plan préétabli
ses créations il les entreprend en
écoutant son instant
en partant d'une plaque qui est là c'est
adverse j'ai mis d'autres plaques en
dessous qui sont là pour faire ce petit
trottoir et puis après j'ai erré couvert
de petites plaques comme ça et
l'ensemble donne l'illusion d'une route
à presque 50 ans le passionné de vie
comme une seconde jeunesse
lorsqu'on grandir on perd cette
innocence que l'oeil de l'enfant mais au
travers de ces petites briques et bien
moi quelque part je retombe un peu en
enfance puisque je me crée un univers
féerique un univers parallèle pour
garder les pieds sur terre joël s'est
fixé une règle ne pas dépenser plus de
500 euros par an dans les petites
briques danoises